>>> WE ARE BACK WITH THE
POLITICS LEAD.
TODAA REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE
FORMY M GOVERNOR APPEARED IN
COURT OVER CHARGES RELATED TO
THE JANUARY 6 CAPITOL
INSURRECTION.
RYAN KELLEY PLEADED NOT GUILTY.
HE CLIMBED THE SCAFFOLDING IN
THE CAPITOL ATTACK AND MOTIONED
FOR RIOTERS TO ADVANCE.
HOURS BEFORE THE COURT
APPEARANCE HE DEFENDED THE
ACTIONS AND IN A DEBATE WITH
OTHER REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES.
LET'S WATCH.
>> WE WERE PROTESTING THE
GOVERNMENT BECAUSE WE DON'T LIKE
THE RESULTS OF THE 2020 ELECTION
PROCESS.
WE HAVE THAT FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHT AND THAT'S WHAT 99% OF THE
PEOPLE WERE THERE FOR.
I SUPPORT PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SO WHAT DO YOU THINK?
HOW MUCH COULD THIS IMPACT THIS
RACE?
>> HE IS RUNNING ON THIS.
NOT RUNNING FROM IT.
NOT SHOWING SHAME.
INVESTIGATORS ARE SAYING YOU
CLIMBED A SCAFFOLDING SO THAT'S
BEYOND FIRST AMENDMENT ACTIVITY
BUT HE KEEPS BRINGING THIS UP
AND BELIEVES THAT DONALD TRUMP
WON IN 2020.
THINK IT IS ELECTION WAS STOLEN
AND JOE BIDEN WON THE STATE BY
154,000 VOTES.
AND IT WAS VERY CLEAR ON THE
DEBATE STAGE THAT THE
REPUBLICANS TRYING TO ONE UP
EACH OTHER ON HOW FAR THEY WERE
IN TRUMP'S CORNER.
IT IS CLEAR THAT KELLEY THINKS
IT IS GOOD FOR HIM IN A
REPUBLICAN PRIMARY.
>> SO LET'S TALK MORE ABOUT LAST
NIGHT DEBATE.
THE REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES ASKED
YES OR NO, DO YOU BELIEVE THE
2020 PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION IN
MICHIGAN WAS STOLEN.
LISTEN TO THE ANSWERS.
>> AND THE ANSWER FOR ME IS
THAT, YES, THE 2020 ELECTION IN
THE STATE OF MICHIGAN WAS
FRAUDULENT AND STOLEN FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> YES.
JUST LIKE HE SAID.
CONTINUE TO SWEEP IT UNDER THE
RUG.
BUT THE PEOPLE DESERVE TO KNOW.
>> WE DON'T KNOW WHERE THE
SECRETARY OF STATE IS CHEATING.
>> THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT
THERE WAS FRAUD.
>> ALL RIGHT.
TO BE CLEAR.
I'LL SAY IT AGAIN.
TRUMP'S TONE ATTORNEY GENERAL
SAID THERE'S NO WIDESPREAD
FRAUD.
IT SEEMS LIKE, ALICE, LISTENING
TO THE ANSWERS IT IS LIKE HOW
HARD CAN YOU HIT HOME THIS LIE
THAT THE ELECTION WAS STOLEN?
STOLEN MORE.
HOW MUCH OF A LITMUS TEST IS
THIS?
>> IN THE MICHIGAN GOP PRIMARY
RACE IT IS A HUGE TEST.
THE REAL TEST IS WHO CAN BE MORE
BIGLEY TRUMP BY SAYING THAT.
THEY NEED TO QUIT RUNNING ON
GRIEVANCES OF THE PAST AND RUN
ON POLICIES OF THE FUTURE.
THEY HAVE 124 DAYS UNTIL THE
NOVEMBER ELECTIONS.
THEY NEED TO TALK ABOUT
INFLATION AND THE ECONOMY, ABOUT
JOBS, CRIME.
THOSE ARE THE ISSUES VOTERS ARE
CONCERNED WITH.
HIM TALKING ABOUT STORMING THE
CAPITOL AND EXERCISING THE FREE
SPEECH.
HE DIDN'T LIKE THE ELECTION
RESULTS.
I DIDN'T STORM THE CAPITOL.
I THINK THAT WILL HURT HIM.
HE HAS RISEN IN THE POLLS AS OF
LATE BUT I THINK THAT WILL COME
BACK TO HAUNT HIM HEARING MORE.
>> THIS SEEMS TO BE A
PREREQUISITE FROM THE REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATES BUT YOU CAN'T WIN ON
THIS ISSUE ALONE.
LOOK AT GEORGIA.
YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO RUN ON
OTHER ISSUES.
I THINK THAT IT IS WORTH NOTING
THAT THIS ISSUE LOOKS DIFFERENT
IN DIFFERENT CANDIDATES.
I COVERED YOUNGKIN'S SUCCESSFUL
RACE IN VIRGINIA.
BUZZ TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
HE WAS NOT OUT THERE TALKING
ABOUT HOW THE ELECTION IS STOLEN
BUT CENTERING INTEGRITY.
THAT'S A WINK AND A NOD I THINK
TO THIS ISSUE.
>> BUT I THINK THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT POINT ABOUT HOW EVEN
THE PEOPLE WHO AREN'T DOING THE
FULL-BLOWN IT WAS STOLEN ALMOST
ALL OF THEM ARE SAYING THINGS
LIKE WE NEED TO LOOK INTO IT.
IT WASN'T TOTALLY FAIR.
THERE ARE CONCERNS.
PEOPLE ARE ASKING QUESTIONS.
VERY FEW OF THEM WILL SAY JOE
BIDEN WON THE ELECTION.
RIGHT?
IT'S BECOME SO CENTRAL AND
OBVIOUSLY EXTREMELY CONCERNING I
THINK TO ANY AMERICAN.
>> DANCE AROUND IT.
>> YEAH.
>> PEOPLE ARE ASKING QUESTIONS.
BECAUSE YOU HA